[Music]
there's this kid he didn't think he
could cut it I figured it was just the
usual jitters I take him under my wing
he was wanting to be scared
Pearl Harbor is the greatest
intelligence failure in American history
this can never happen again
I want to make it right
least some of the boys still want to
fight
the Japanese are planning something
bigger so what's the target
we believe it's Midway Washington
disagrees Washington is wrong if we lose
then Japanese on the west coast Seattle
San Francisco Los Angeles Oh burn
we've got the order to launch we need to
throw a punch so they know what it feels
like to be hit
a lot a couple dozen planes it's all
Japanese fleet
this isn't a fair fight
ladies man
you know that you came to
when people accountant
you'll be able to face anything
what the hell is be fewer turning
himself into a bomb
Diann Bruna aren't they playing us to
kill Jess Admiral Halsey wants to see
you
you've memorized every position on that
board lady go home I think I'm going to
spend the night here sir just in case
anything comes up your wife doesn't mind
well she knows the drill my wife knows
the drill too but she's still mines now
when the war's over I plan on spending
the rest of my life making it up to her
some rest
good night
[Music]
Hey hi I got a stable
[Music]
wait have you met and Wade McCluskey I
fly with your husband
hey you want to drink I do you want me
to dance
you know welcome
how long have you been married long
enough to know my husband's talents
why isn't he commanding a squadron I
don't make those decisions - my turn
yes I understand before the war when it
was about politics but now I told you
she was a firecracker huh I have to say
I often wondered what kind of woman
would marry dick bastard well you have
not disappointed Pearl Harbor is the
greatest intelligence failure in
American history the Japanese are
playing something bigger what's the
target
we believe it's Midway Midway was one of
the key battles of World War two this is
the greatest military comeback story in
history this is actually what happened
everybody was very conscientious about
trying to make it real
[Music]
being historically accurate is still
unbelievable epic and exciting
my dad was in World War two my
grandfather was in these battles there's
a personal connection there I was very
lucky to be given real wings from
Louisville to I could appreciate this
was on another man's chest that
generation sacrificed so much for all of
us first they'll be bigger than
themselves you know that you came
through when people were counting on you
you'll be able to face anything
you